all right Matt rooster Mike rooster oh
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally my head of Texas Man by way
of Dallas Texas scary hairy man you did
tell me about your uh the way you grew
up you had both your parents when you
were young yeah me and my my dad man he
went to the penetration when I was about
11 going on 12 years old my mom I had
both my parents both my grandparents I
had everybody you know everybody was
dedicated to me you know I didn't have
no rough childhood good chocolate yeah I
just when I jumped off the porch I just
was an [__] because I wanted to be I
didn't have to be I never seen no big
time struggle none of that [__]
everything was what rooster wanted to do
he did what I'm saying so all the chaos
and conflict the hell I caused on my
mama my grandmothers
is my [__] and they started what age
man I think I got it
I got to tripping and [__] about 15
years old you finished high school
I went to the 10th grade
after 10th grade I stopped going and
then I went back and I got a GED oh you
did yes sir when you were in prison no
I've never been to prison I marked my
body up like this just acting a damn
fool man I went to county jail and [__]
like that but man I ain't never been in
no penitentiary in my life how old are
you
16 years old now I'm just [__] with
now I'm 31 man 31. you're like 16. look
60. I appreciate it you could pass for
16. trying to stay young
and uh how'd you get an interest to the
game
let me show you a lot a lot of
[__] ain't gonna want to hear
this man because I know a lot of people
they hate this lifestyle and [__] like
this man but I'm gonna keep it 100 man a
woman turned me on
that happens a lot doesn't it you know
what I'm saying everybody come up with
all this old sex trafficking [__] and
all this old man he forcing her to do
this [__] what you gonna say when what
you're gonna say when you get somebody
in front of in front of you and they
tell you man
a woman showed me this [__] a woman that
I really liked you know
you know what I'm saying a woman that
you might have been in love with
then what we got you're gonna lock her
up
you know what I'm saying you're gonna
lock that [__] up for showing me how to
do this [__]
died that day
how many girls you got today
she
you ain't catching a bunch of you so
[__] about two million
[__] now I'm hopeless man
I'm hopeless
and when uh
when you when you find a girl what
qualities do you look for
no man I you know a lot of guys that go
out and they try to look for the most
broke down type women man is it really
don't take that man it don't you don't
have to really [__] with nobody this
got no issues no no mental health
problems and [__] like that man I
I pose and get told Mark you know what
I'm saying like I don't I don't go out
looking for no
no woman that I feel like she weak or no
[__] like that man man her caliber got a
match mine now I'm not saying my door
not open to you know
a woman that just ain't got nobody and
she just looking for the right you know
what I'm saying she just looking for the
right guy that's looking for the right
[__] to come into her life and
change it
that ain't where my eyes at but you know
I like women as
they in the right mind up here man they
a woman smarter than a man they mature
faster than a man so
that's a turn on for me right there
because even though I might be
you know dishing out game we selling
game how the [__] you want to call it
man you know what I'm saying
some realism man he he got his ear to
the streets he got his ear to the floor
to his hoe you know what I'm saying I
hope it put you on a lot of [__] I hope
it turned you up you know what I'm
saying that's what I always been open to
the woman
you know what I'm saying listening to it
you got to be there for
you know [__] think this is
some Hollywood [__] beat this [__] up
bring me some money [__] get out there
give me some [__] money [__]
now man a lot of these women
man they they out here
they they come to you you know they
trusting in you they believing that you
got the mindset
to you know laughing to get this [__]
my month I'm gonna get this [__] my
money man and I pray he do right with it
because you got some man you got some
hoes out here man they paying stop signs
like what we saying the guy man he's
giving no money to a [__] they don't
know what he doing
you know what I'm saying she might give
her money too
to a no thing
you'll say hey man Dopey wear regular
clothes and [__] like this man dopey's
ain't always walking around
you know looking [__] up dirty looking
like they ain't baby man you got some
dope things to be flying to be what do
you see your Royal ass are you like
their money manager or their
psychologist or
Father Figure or what are you
[__] might get some backlash for
this [__] I'm about to say man you they
man
you when when you when you have a when
you have a prostitute
you're you're married to her not
literally like a ring on a finger and we
writing down you know I'm saying we
writing down vows and [__]
you are for her and for her only you
know you got [__] out here it's
like
a Square's biggest line is you [__] your
hoes you don't want a square woman meets
a pimp she'll ask you like you [__] your
hoes
who else he supposed to [__]
who else he supposed to have sex with
because you you want to know some real
[__] though mark
you got a prostitute right here man
let's say you got half a minute it don't
even matter one two three four it don't
matter
man you [__] outside that stable a
[__] that's calling himself some
ISM you [__] outside that stable she
gonna leave your [__] ass a
real one is you [__] a [__] that's not
paying you
you don't say if you [__] a [__] that
ain't paying you man man them hoes down
they catch wind of this [__]
you know what I'm saying that's that's
what I'm saying man it's not
it's not a a force thing this is a
choice game
so when that woman comes to you man she
coming to you like she will come to a
[__] that she want to marry
she trusting you
she putting her all into you
you all she got
most of the time
see a diva from New Wave hoes man they
coming out the street they looking
busted [__] up man hey man he hoes out
here having fun because they really
checking some cash Mark you know what
I'm saying he hoes out here checking
some money
you know what I'm saying I ain't I ain't
talking about
no [__] you don't say you see the hoes
in the flip-flops and [__] and they look
[__] up Dusty you know who look like
they've been sitting in the heat all day
man man hell now man these [__] red
bottom stepping man you know what I'm
saying I thought they heard did you you
know
they coming you don't say they coming
jazzed up
how does it work in Dallas where you
work it's you know there's a track there
and uh yeah for sure you know attract
track everywhere and ain't nobody gonna
stop it but a lot of guys are doing
things online now and things like that
yeah yeah yeah you're gonna have that
you gonna have that man it's you know
it's a good use a model around the board
man you ain't playing got to be all
around the board you know
you got to be all around the board man
and see that goes It goes back to when I
would explain it to you about you know
see I didn't get into it about my dad my
dad's a white man
you know my mom's black
you know I know a lot of people they
might mistake for being Hispanic but
I called my dad my cheat sheet and I'm
not trying to say he's smart because
he's a white man but the way my my
father raised me
he raised me
it wasn't cool to act the [__]
fool even when my daddy would gone to
the penitentiary because my dad he you
know what I'm saying he did everything
you know that a black man would and he
never tried to act black
my dad never thought he was black
he never
wanted to fit in he just was himself and
he hustled
but he outsmarted a lot of [__] he was
smart
you know so
me coming
into the game
everything my dad taught me I brought
that [__] into the game that's what a
lot of [__] never knew about me
I marked in the past man when I had some
hoes man any [__] that left me the [__]
alone man she wasn't right up here
cause I ain't never do no [__] nothing
I ain't never did no [__] bad
never you know what I'm saying I know
how you know he's pimping and we
pimpsing hoes like look at how look at
that [__] hey man
in the household man that's my woman
no matter how many of them it is
that's my woman man your girl's gotta
like you right yeah I mean that's why I
tell you pose and get chose like I ain't
I ain't going out for the you know
saying like we ain't put
me and my partner we're in public
I probably won't say nothing first
but if I if I see you catch eye contact
and I feel like they're feeling this
Mutual yeah man
is there
you know but I ain't gonna be doing a
[__]
hooping and hollering you know if you
turned out squares before yeah I turned
down squares every day
I turned down squares every day and a
lot of them they don't understand
like why you know what I'm saying like
why
like why why you know what I'm saying
they feel like they get a pass
you know you got all of this oh I ain't
gotta sell my [__] [__] you [__] with
hoes sell they [__] I ain't gotta sell
my [__] [__] you can't see your [__]
cause a trigger hurts your [__]
feelings that's what a lot of women
don't know you already women Martin like
man I don't see how they do that and
then got that [__] up [__] at night
I don't see how she walk a track you
hear me man oh yeah she walk the tracks
she gonna see a little [__] and then
they come to me hey you [__] with them
with them no no
girlfriend it ain't about him being with
it [__] Mark man let me taste them like
how you asked about that track you got
some hoes that might think they the
baddest [__] in the world man
yeah I know my worth I never do that all
right [__] get your ass out there here
huh let's see how many treats hurt your
[__] feeling when you're gonna
pop this you feel like you worth a
thousand bucks how when you you see the
trick pull up and tell your code 60. you
did
you know what I'm saying then you
looking around like
oh they sending 60 dollars
because that's your word hoe
you know what I'm saying
and I ain't trying to talk and make
[__] hate me man that's just a
Game Boy you know what I'm saying that's
just
I'm a great dude man
if if a [__] take time to really
know me
so but really though mark
in the past
don't nobody know don't nobody know what
people for real but his hoes so in the
past [__] with them hoes man
nobody know me but my whole
my mama my daddy my granny
my stepmother
them the [__] they really know
me they know my heart
you know what I'm saying they know what
he's eating for
you know what I'm saying you gotta have
sense man you're not forcing or tricking
or coercing your girls into being with
you right because the door turned on
both sides
it ain't the the it's a doe knob on both
sides man
you know what I'm saying
you come in you come out just like just
like when them hoes handed just like
when them hoes hand in the ears with
some money that's like an ATM machine
you gotta reciprocate that [__] man you
still gotta take care of man
[__] the pimping my site you just take
this take this little girl money
say man he he hoes and leave you man
they'll get they'll get away from you
you know what they'll do they'll go to
another [__] and they'll tell him
I ain't you know man rooster
yeah [__] I know him
that [__] be [__] my money off
do you want to see me
hey man when I first came in this [__]
back to him I said what happened I was
playing
I heard [__]
the chick man the chick I told you about
that turned me up
I used to hear it from her all the time
you're a [__] squirter
she's a team to get pimping little [__]
you know what I'm saying I used to have
to get my feelings hurt by that [__]
see I got a buddy of mine that really
really put me on game and I paid for
that you know what I'm saying a buddy of
mine really turned me up but but that
woman that first one
let me tell you story on that man I was
this was basically like a girlfriend man
I was back and forth between her and my
baby and mama man
you know what I'm saying my baby mama
like me say man my baby mama leave me
I go over and [__] him up
and man I I ain't gonna say that I was
using them
but she was just down for me
at all costs man and I one day man I had
her with me and I walked in a you know
in a recording studio you know you know
I'm an artist out of Dallas I walked in
a recording studio man and I
my partner he looked he said man who was
that
and I said I told him who I said man you
know that's who I was telling you about
and he said
he said man that's a hoe
and I said I said man hell no that ain't
No Hoe he said man that's a hoe man and
you know by this time I had been [__]
with this this partner of mind for some
time and I was just interested because
he was full-blown active in the game he
was full-blown pimping
and he you know he said let's just start
right there you know
I said man hell now
this man I went home with her man and I
asked her you know we was talking
I said man would you would you dance for
me like you know I'm just green as [__]
man you know what I'm saying would you
would you would you uh you gonna shake
your ass me you don't say you get up in
the club for me she was like yeah she
was like I would I'll do that for you I
was like you give me 30 of the money
I said you give me 30 of the money man
and she kind of looked she thought about
that [__] you know she was like yeah man
you know because she'll do anything for
me
so tired went by man we was doing that
man we were arguing some more [__] Mark
you know what I'm saying we go through
so much [__] bro and it was just getting
it it wasn't it wasn't no pimping
it was a bunch of macking going on and
some bunch of [__]
but man she got knocked man
she got knocked
by some real dearism
knocked up man
and
we didn't talk for about six seven
months
I started getting my feet wet with other
[__] you know with other hoes
just bullshitting you know playing with
the game
man
whatever term she fell on with that dude
man she came back she turned me up but
she hurt my feelings though a lot and I
know [__] like man you got your
feelings hurt [__] you the Pippin [__]
pip ain't got no [__] feeling
now as a man when you coming in that
game and you don't know what the [__]
you doing
and you hear a house like [__] you
squirt in a [__] [__] you [__] you
ain't about [__] [__] you ain't no pimp
man a [__] that really woke that [__]
that'll turn down man
he ain't trying to hear that [__]
get pimping little [__]
ain't not trying to hurt it
a [__] didn't feel like he really doing
it
ain't listening to that [__]
you were lacking the leadership skills
yeah not just not knowing with it just
really wanting the image of that [__]
and not knowing what come with it
man she has some [__] going on with her
car I'm like man this your job [__]
you're saying this huh like she you
don't say a time flesh you need to get a
new whatever the hell on her card he
truly you know what I'm saying they true
events like my degree show job so you
know you learn that lesson the hard way
how you learned that lesson the hard way
yeah
you know because anything that come with
this woman like I said it go back to you
know what I'm saying when you ate like
it's like your wife
it's not just somehow off the streets
you're dedicated to her
and she's dedicated to you and she's
dedicated to you there ain't no outside
of that [__] a lot of things a lot of
things squares don't understand about
this game that make it really seem
hard for us hard for a square to
process
I think I think it's just because the
girls come from the streets as as do you
very often The Pimps and it's a culture
that's that's very mysterious to to
squares yeah and man I ain't a lot of
Team Mark that that chick I'm telling
you about man she got degrees I mean
[__] feel great school teacher
you know what I'm saying like it is
just because you're educated or she's
educated doesn't mean that you guys
still aren't from the streets yeah
exactly like
the guy might for dummies The Dope Game
the pimp game this [__] ain't for
dumbasses
you know what I'm saying you gotta have
it up here you gotta have some sense
that's all it takes I mean
I would tell you my dad my dad ain't
grow up like that man my dad won't know
when no [__] gangster
he was a regular white boy from here
Texas
you ever heard of my head Texas no
that's where Anna Nicole Smith from you
know who that is I do yes I do it's the
country man like an hour outside of
Dallas right you know
my dad man he
he stepped into that but he was smart
enough to know you know so he trained
his mind to know like he he mastered the
streets he mastered being that gangster
without having to really just act like
one you don't understand what I'm saying
and see a lot of people thought I was
gonna follow my dad footsteps and
thought I was gonna be some big time
dope dealer you know
with a whole bunch of kids and some old
[__]
you know everybody thought that of me
man I was a bums and I was 26 years old
Mark I ain't gonna go live man I ain't
gonna be one of these Captain ass
[__] up here act like man [__]
out here dude Mark out [__] till I
was 26 gang banging and some old [__]
you're you're maybe one of the more
honest man I'm Gonna Keep I'm Gonna Keep
on this and that's one and anybody
trying to [__] with this game I had a
guy just ask me man I need some game man
with all that Honesty bro you need to be
honest I hear it a lot from the jump you
need to be honest just like how we
talking about squares you you know why
these squares feel like they can just
have their way with pimps and [__]
it's because there's a lot of
[__] that's playing they give
them the go-ahead like man they'll go
[__] with these square holes I'm not
just for you to frown up on me and tell
me
I don't [__] with that [__] you they
pimp you my boyfriend [__] [__] no
[__] no
hell no
you know what I'm saying it don't go
like that
you gotta stand on you know what I'm
saying you got to stand on what you
believe in and like you said
honesty
you got to be honest I'm gonna be honest
with a square I'm a square woman like me
I'm not gonna turn this off
I'm not gonna Chill on this [__] I'm not
gonna come to your house and hey man
leave this [__] outside nah [__] this
is me
yeah I I like I like rooster I don't
like mac rooster the pimp I like I see
beyond that now what you see is some
[__] ism
that's what you're liking
because if I if whatever you seeing
beyond that [__] you it's you in the
desert somewhere looking at a [__]
Mirage [__] right there with that car
more you seeing things man
you feel me right because
you you just seeing [__]
cause I can't turn this button on and
off man
you you you program your mind and it's
this [__] this [__] like this is a
mindset man
you know them you know the morality code
of this [__]
a lot of [__] Man Mark I see a
lot of [__] coming here man I just be
looking at them up but like she's
supposed right here
man hey
I don't do no drugs I don't smoke I
don't drink not knocking that my
partners they smoke I I'm not I could be
around in a room with some weed smoke in
the air it don't bother me that's just
not my thing I can't handle the high
I'm really a nerd geek Mark you know
what I'm saying
I really nothing wrong with that I see
Ron Wheatie and the Gang helped me
come to the realization that I can voice
that [__]
and my partners
they still [__] with me anyway
you did what I'm saying they gonna [__]
with me anyway because I'm genuine and
you know I'm saying I ain't got a lie I
ain't got a lot of kick it man a lot of
[__] lying the kid
you did what I'm saying
I'm not gonna do that
I'm not gonna tell no lies I'm not gonna
fake and shake with nobody not gonna lie
down up damn shot not gonna lie to no
woman I'm not gonna lie to my partners
I'm not gonna lie to my mama I'm not
gonna lie to my daddy
you know
man they did they work on me more
my stepmom and my real mom they raised
me together and my grandmother
both my grandmothers
man they man they they did what they
could with me I was [__] up
I apologize to my mom when I was about
23 24 years old because man I just sit
back one day and I was like man I was
hoe ass dude
I was [__] up
and you know I would
how my mom and How firm my mom was
and now I got I got kids man I
understand that [__] now man
and I'm getting all that [__] back
everything I gave my mama my granny them
while my daddy was gone I really was
just a just a mad kid that my daddy was
gone because my daddy was in my little
white boy you did what I'm saying I love
him you know what I'm saying I'm not no
[__] that I don't [__] with my
daddy [__] that [__] now man my daddy
was for real in my life even when he
went and did his beard
man I did what rooster wanted to do
you did what I'm saying I did I did what
rooster wanted to do until my mama just
you know
my grandmother on my white side that's
the only one I couldn't do no wrong with
her eyes like right now my grandmother
gone now but right now
did she probably wrote In The Grave
knowing I'm on some ISM you know what
I'm saying she probably don't understand
this [__]
if she was here but
she would have my back I went through
family issues with this game oh I heard
you explain it to your to your
grandmother she would just she would
know what's going on because the way I
was with my grandmother I probably just
walked through the door with my [__]
like you know what I'm saying if I was
to show up just like I do my dad like me
and my dad we we got on some bad terms
at first you know what I'm saying and at
first he didn't believe it he thought I
was just but when you pull up at your
grandmother's house if she was still
alive in your fur coat and three girls
what do you say to her
they are with me and she just gonna look
baby who are they you know it's my white
grandmother now you know what I'm saying
is
she gonna she gonna put two and two
together
no shame though
she gonna feed them they gonna sit down
at the table she gonna cook
she gonna cook and do some more [__]
if she was still here because there's
respect with you and your girls you
treat them with respect they treat you
the same
yeah man when I when I wasn't how old is
Yo
yeah man is is is a respect I mean it's
like I said you treat them as as your
why now I know you you know what I'm
saying you said look at that [__] hand
me that [__] look at how hand me that
I ain't gonna say that just for sure
yeah that's that that's the game that's
that's that's that's the culture of that
[__] but you know man I ain't gonna just
sit here and climb like I'm some BFE
type [__] but you know
men and women and women love you
they giving you that money
you know what I'm saying you got this
woman go out here make thousand thousand
dollars and bring that [__] you think
she ain't got no type of feeling for you
a [__] crazy if he think not
just like these [__] they they about
their [__] about them hoes they
gonna look at something behind them hoes
you know what I'm saying I show up
always laugh at me when I say that
that's from Texas [__]
I go look at some man
yeah you probably that's his money
you know what I'm saying that's his
money he probably thinking about his
about his cash flow
but mentally
many hoe is everything
no matter how many it is over there
unless it just fly by nights you know
what I'm saying but you know you will
know who
you know who really got a real deal
solid stiff relationship with their work
man you'll know you'll know you know
what I'm saying because when you show up
to the you show up to these [__] don't
step you
you serve when you get them papers you
know how they go Mark when you serve a
[__] they papers
and they be ready to kill you man
so you do the math on that on how on how
they're getting treated and you got a
lot of girls and oh forcing it is all
forces no you're not because every time
I got you mentioned how you mentioned
the track
anytime you get out that [__]
car [__] you can run to any Police
Department
but you there because you want to be
I already did we gonna get the sex
trafficking [__] that [__] right there
is [__] stupid
now if you [__] with the kids
yeah man you need your ass home buy a
rope man you all saying you need you
need to be thrown in the slam up under
that [__] and you [__] with
some little kid [__] you can't pimp on
the ground woman [__] you don't need to
be in the game
you did what I'm saying
you can't pimp on no ground woman
I ain't gonna say pimp on you can't get
no money with no grown woman
you don't need to be [__] around
you the [__] got to be here with you
like I told you women mature faster than
men they say you don't say you in your
30s you got your [__] 25 26 you know
what I'm saying her mind kind of there
with you you know what I'm saying
you got [__] out here playing with
either 16 15 year old girl [__] that's
easy
that's easy
when you hold your title for that for a
couple of dollars cause ain't nobody
finna get a little out that little bitty
ass kid you know no cash flow they just
not
you gonna run the wheels off of a
[__] ass on that track and just
[__] her little mind frame but she gonna
think that's just what that is
For Eternity for the rest of her you
know what I'm saying well-being
I don't want no [__] little ass
kids
I need to like I told you he'll be
having degrees man them how to get a
dose of their lifestyle and [__] they
see man that's that's some [__]
money like how we singing you got to be
smart you got to be educated in it you
know what I'm saying because you got to
ask smart the [__] watching you
got the police watching
you know what I'm saying you got the
[__] trying to knock you
you know I
man say I'ma tell you
what you put out in this game you get
that [__] back man
I believe in that you know how you
aiming for they believe in karma and
[__] like that
I believe in the game God
and I ain't just talking about it just
pipping and holding the gang guard and
every [__] in anything Street
he'll come back and he'll Cut You Down
cut your legs right off
you did what I'm saying
he'll punish you Mike
I believe that Mark
all right Chris here thank you so much
you did
we should invest the luck out there no
death take care of your girls
if I give me some
[Laughter]
thank you man
uh really